nous vous parlions cette semaine de cet
événement à pithiviers dans le loiret la
création d'un nouveau lieu de mémoire de
la shoah dont l'ancienne gare de
voyageurs vont soir christine launay
comme si notre région a accueilli des
camps d'internement durant la seconde
guerre mondiale alors oui la shoah la
politique d'extermination des juifs mise
en place par les nazis fut il faut le
savoir soutenu par le gouvernement de
vichy une responsabilité dans ce
génocide que jacques chirac fut le
premier homme d'état français à
reconnaître en 1995 alors dans notre
région de 1941 à 1943 plus de 18000
juifs dont près de 4000 enfants furent
internés dans les camps de beaune la
rolande et de pithiviers dans le loiret
avant d'être déportés vers les camps
d'extermination
située dans l'actuelle pologne alors la
région centre val de loire a compté
durant l'occupation
donc entre 1940 et 1944 de multiples
centres de rassemblement des étrangers
ou des espagnols des polonais des
étrangers sans papiers fut retenu
prisonnier au total une vingtaine de
camps de rétention parfois provisoire ou
pouvait être interné aussi des militants
politiques comme ce fut le cas à voves
en un en eure-et-loir pardon à partir
d'août 1942 au moment de la grande ralph
rafle pardon des juifs étrangers
organisée par vichy certains de ces
centres vont être chargé de trier les
juifs c'est le cas de celui de douadic
dans l'indre devenu un camp de transit
alors où les personnes arrêtées seront
ensuite transférés en haute vienne avant
leur départ pour drancy puis vers le
camp d'extermination d'auschwitz alors
la shoah elle a fait 80 mille victimes
en france 55 mille étaient des juifs
étrangers et on estime que près de trois
quarts des juifs de france ont pu
échapper à la déportation grâce à l'aide
de la population française des justes
des résistants des associations ou
encore avec le soutien de l'église
catholique
merci beaucoup christine pour cet
éclairage